hello there
citizens of the
reject nation
we got ourselves a john wick chapter 4
subtitle comic con
john which kills everyone in san diego
everyone in the comic con is an assassin
they're all looking for him
who doesn't love this john wick
franchise if you don't comment below and
then we're gonna send everyone after you
guys leave a like um so also also also
subscribe and click that notification
bell got a lot of comic-con goodies to
cover koi jaundra was just wood killers
i just hosted the whole h panel that it
was for berserker and i want to thank my
fiancee for my keanu shirt
anywho guys enough beating around the
bush i know nothing about this sequel
nor do i haven't read anything about it
no this will be a surprise other than
everyone everyone's always looking for
john wick all right let's go let's do it
[Music]
have you given any thought
to where this ends
no way he's in this the table will never
stop
you know this
that clancy brown
look kind of like clancy brown yeah
no one
skarsgard
whoa
bow and
ready john
was that donny yen
that's who i thought it was
yeah
as a john wick yeah
holy [ __ ]
dude
oh bowery king that was great we're
watching that again i don't care what
anyone says no no no this is that donnie
yen that would be done nuts if that's
donnie yen it looked just like him the
next logic i'm sure there's one google
one google stuff i am making the google
search all right here we go get ready it
done again it is donnie donnie yen scott
atkins oh man we're watching that again
normally the john wick teaser trailers
the first ones are always like oh this
is cool but you know the movie's gonna
be like so much cooler than what it is
and this one was like no this is the
john wick action yeah
starting out in the snow let's do it
again
traditional martial arts action thought
where this
ends the table will never stop
you know this that is clean
give me more hand-to-hand action
it's like bill skarsgard so he's like
the main bad guy yeah hey i think i saw
donnie yen behind him yeah he was over
his shoulder
i love that shot
love the shot kind of the beat he's got
somebody too that is totally dotty yes
so
is he playing a blind character
yeah
this is like more martial arts
got the dog back too yeah
who's shooting in mid-air
i love it so much
i love it so much
oh i
wow you noticed so much more in the
second watch i know all those quick
flashes then you yeah you start you
realize as the trailer goes the first
time just how many people are in this
movie and then the second time around
yeah it forces you to examine the whole
frame i was thinking that this one would
start off moments after where the third
one ended where he's just
like a [ __ ] he's crawling out of a
dumpster
yeah and you're just watching him heal
the whole movie like like one of those
boring netflix episodes you're like god
get to the action it's the one where he
goes to the safe house and spends a lot
of time in recovery yeah it's just this
meditative film just building the finale
but no some kind of time jump happened
here it's interesting because he just
had matrix four come out which did not
have larry fishman no
i wonder now they're back together here
dude they gotta get carrie anne moss in
here i swear to god oh the fifth one
let's do it they to do it but having
donnie yen one of the greatest martial
arts action stars of all time going
toe-to-toe with keanu reeves in real
life donnie yen would have whooped that
man's ass no doubt about it yes it's not
can you he almost looks like the less
[ __ ] version of uh of alfie allen or
theon greyjoy in the first movie do you
think he's gonna actually kill winston
his name winston yeah right um let's
double check what's an actor's name ian
shane yeah winston yep yeah yeah do you
think he's gonna kill winston this time
man i'm so torn because i feel like this
[ __ ] him over a lot yeah i feel like
he would have to but i also feel like
part of the one of the bread and butter
aspects of the series since the
beginning and the cast has been in
mcshane so part of me is like maybe
they'll find a convoluted way to elevate
his status and keep him going but i
think especially on the heels of the
last movie with the ending like you know
everyone generally loves john wick but
the last movie ends in a way where
you're like guys we're getting into
superhero territory with this guy now so
it might reinforce the stakes to have it
be like nah he really caps winston in
this movie you go into superhero
territory by the amount he can survive
but what keeps this movie so the
franchise so visceral and impactful you
could tell it's a lot of real stuntmen
yeah doing like even keanu reeves on top
of that windshield all the cars driving
back towards it turned over bang bang
bang bang you know i've done that in
real life many times oh yeah so i was
just on the 405.
it's like i'm trying to catch my plane
get out of the way inching along
yeah
it's not like 60 miles per hour
it's like five miles per hour
like i hate you
um yeah man but it looks like the bowery
king and him are truly teaming up this
time yeah
which will make up for matrix 4. they
have a real it sounds like a vendetta
where they're really going to help each
other out actual actual partnership but
yeah this is a great trailer
this is a a great great first trailer
can't wait for this film subscribe click
that bell button this with a pic
chris wham-off look chris we always talk
about how nice of a guy you are how
generous you are
but let's face it there's a side of you
that is like john wick oh yeah there's a
dude out there when injustice is done
you just want to go out in the streets
yeah
pop some kindness
of justice to you yeah oh that's what
you mean the bullets are made of cotton
ballists are made of celtic kinds
they're like cupid uh arrows yeah with
bullets i get where you're getting at
now cupid bullets is what you provide in
the world you're john wick full of love
a loving master you're like the
christian book version of john wick when
a christian book goes
we need to appeal to the youth
i know let's make john wick like jesus
and let's give him
yes give him love bullets that's right
let's use yours into a crowd and
instead of dying let's use all the most
problematic iconography to appeal to the
youth while swapping into this clever
message about jesus shocking triggering
imagery is what you provide but it
always ends with love you subvert
expectations
so
that's what you are man your bullets for
christ
thank you
chris swam off for being here for so
long and
we'll talk soon but
[Music]